digamos que esta soy yo en esta columna
de aquí
y aquí estás tú en esta otra columna de
acá
imaginemos que tú tienes una deliciosa y
roja manzana que trataré de dibujar
apropiadamente así que tú tienes una
deliciosa manzana y yo tengo hambre
quisiera comerme una manzana y yo
supongo que ya que tú tienes esa manzana
en tu mano yo supongo que tú eres el
dueño de ella así que me acerco a ti y
te digo oye te puedo comprar esa manzana
y tú me dices y claro yo no lo necesito
te la vendo por un dólar así que yo te
doy un dólar
y tú me das esta deliciosa manzana así
que ahora yo lo tengo y parece que es la
manzana se aplastó un poquito en la
transacción
supongo que sigue igual de deliciosa así
que ahora yo tengo una manzana y en esta
transacción hubieron algunas
suposiciones que yo hice yo supuse que
la posición de la manzana era el
equivalente de ser dueño de la manzana
así que yo supuse que la posición era
igual a ser dueño del objeto en este
caso de la manzana y tú me podrías decir
bueno en qué circunstancias puede
ocurrir esto bueno a mí se me ocurre que
a lo mejor tú te encontraste la manzana
en el jardín de tu vecino y el verdadero
dueño de esa manzana es tu vecino o
quizás tomaste esta manzana de una
tienda o quizá la encontraste en la
banca de un parque y como no viste na de
alrededor puedes pensarse que podrías
tomarla llevártela pero quizás alguien
más la había dejado por un momento en la
banca ibarra
y darse cuenta de que ya no está su
manzana así que pueden ver que incluso
en el caso de una manzana la posesión no
es necesariamente equivalente a ser el
dueño del objeto así que estos dos
conceptos no son equivalentes pero por
algo tan pequeño como una manzana que
quizás pues no es financieramente tan
importante pues es algo que vale un
dólar
quizá sería demasiado problema el estar
rastreando al verdadero dueño de la
manzana hacer un análisis forense para
saber de cual jardín salió esta manzana
o ver si alguien más tiene derecho legal
sobre ella así que para cosas como las
manzanas pues nosotros tendemos a
realizar las transacciones suponiendo
que la posición es igual a hacer dueño
del objeto bueno ahora veamos un ejemplo
un poco más sofisticado en lugar de una
manzana imaginemos que estamos hablando
de una casa
esta casa amarilla tan bonita que tiene
su puerta sus ventanas
tiene también un jardín tiene plantas
alrededor
y tú estás en posesión de esta bonita
casa amarilla y qué significa tener
posesión de la casa bueno significa que
tú estás viviendo en ella tú tienes las
llaves de esta casa tienes tu camioneta
en el estacionamiento de la casa todas
tus cosas están en el closet tus muebles
están en la casa hay fotos tuyas en las
paredes así que todo indica que tú estás
en posesión de la casa y además pones un
letrero de se vende enfrente de esta
casa y yo acabo de llegar a esta ciudad
y necesito un lugar para vivir para mí
para mi familia así que veo esta casa y
digo oye pues está muy bonita me
gustaría comprarla así que yo voy
contigo y te digo oye esta casa me gusta
mucho me gustaría comprarla en cuanto la
estás vendiendo puedes es tú me dices
bueno la estoy vendiendo en 100 mil
dólares me pareció un precio razonable
comparado con el costo de otras casas en
este mismo rumbo por lo que quiero
comprarla y tú dices muy bien entonces
yo te extiende un cheque o incluso
quizás tenga yo el efectivo y te pueda
pagar los 100 mil dólares en él
por lo que esa es una transacción
bastante más seria que la de comprar una
manzana y a cambio de que yo te doy el
dinero tú me das las llaves de la casa
ahora tengo las llaves de la casa aquí
dibujo las llaves y tú me dices dame una
hora en lo que saco mis cosas en pacas
todo en tu camioneta y te vas y yo digo
bueno ahora me puedo mudar a esta casa
pero quizás ustedes están imaginando que
hay algo sospechoso aquí algo que no nos
hace sentir tan confiados durante esta
transacción al menos en comparación con
esta transacción de la manzana pues aún
cuando esta persona tenga las llaves de
la casa y esté viviendo en ella no
necesariamente significa que es dueño de
la casa nuevamente la posesión no
necesariamente implica ser dueño de ella
y podemos imaginar muchos escenarios en
donde la posición de una casa no
implique ser dueño de estas quizás
estaban rentando la casa
eran invitados en la casa y los
verdaderos dueños se encontraban afuera
trabajando y quizás las fotos que vimos
en las paredes son porque la persona que
nos vendió la casa es pariente de los
verdaderos dueños de ésta así pues
quizás eran invitados en la casa o
incluso vieron una casa vacía ya que es
la casa de veraneo de otra persona y
dijeron bueno yo sé que esta casa nadie
la habita durante el verano así que voy
allá cambio las cerraduras para tener
las llaves y voy a simular que vivo ahí
trataré de encontrar a alguien que no
sea de por estos rumbos a quien le pueda
vender esta casa por 100 mil dólares
y si ustedes piensan que todas estas
ideas son cosas muy extrañas y poco
probable de que sucedan créanme que
realmente todas estas cosas han sucedido
en el pasado ya que hay personas cuya
ética es cuestionable y también que no
tienen escrúpulos los cuales estarían
muy tentados de hacer esto sobre todo
cuando se trata de una cantidad fuerte
de dinero por lo que muchas personas
planean fraudes muy elaborados también
podría darse el caso como en las
manzanas en las que alguien dejo la
manzana en la banca del parque y otra
persona se le encontró y pensó que no
tenía dueño y por eso se le lleva esto
podría darse no necesariamente con
fraudes podría ser una persona que pensó
que había heredado esta casa pero
después aparece algún otro pariente más
cercano o con más derechos para heredar
la y dice sabes que tú no puedes vender
a esa casa tú eres el yerno del dueño
pero yo soy su hermano menor o yo soy su
hijo perdido o alguna otra cosa similar
así que quizás ustedes pensar
que eran dueños de la casa legalmente
pero quizás haya otras personas que
están reclamando la incluso puede que
ustedes hayan comprado la casa o creído
que la compraban sin saber que el dueño
anterior tenía la casa en disputa con su
hermano o con su hermana por lo que esta
casa podría tener otras reclamaciones la
forma en que se trata esto en la
sociedad moderna es tratar de ver quién
es el dueño de esta casa
o de saber quién tiene el título que lo
certifica como dueño de la propiedad
quién tiene el título o la escritura o
lo que es lo mismo la prueba de que es
el dueño de esta casa cuando hablamos de
título nos referimos al derecho de la
propiedad el derecho de vivir en la casa
el derecho de modificarla de estar
alrededor de ella así que la pregunta de
quién tiene el título o la evidencia de
título se da mediante documentos legales
y esos documentos legales se les llama
escritura la escritura de la casa si yo
quiero comprarte la casa ti tú y yo
tendremos que encontrar un abogado hacer
un borrador de la escritura y que el
abogado haga la transferencia de la
propiedad de ti hacia mí pero esto sigue
sin comprobar me a mí que en la casa no
tiene ningún problema y es por eso que
yo voy a hacer una búsqueda de
escrituras de la casa hay compañías que
se dedican a hacer búsquedas de títulos
y de escrituras ellos van al registro
público de la propiedad de la ciudad o
del condado
a buscar todas las escrituras que se han
hecho sobre esta propiedad que se
encuentran registradas en la ciudad ya
que si se hace propiamente una escritura
tiene que registrarse públicamente debe
archivarse en la ciudad o condado así
que cuando se hace una búsqueda de
escrituras
esta investigación quienquiera que la
haga va a ir al registro público para
encontrar todas las escrituras previas
que existen sobre esta casa desde el
dueño que nos vendió la casa la
escritura del dueño anterior e incluso
la del dueño anterior a este y se van a
asegurar que la transferencia de
escritura se hayan hecho sin problemas
estén limpias no haya reclamaciones
extrañas sobre la casa o que hayan
gravámenes sobre esto más adelante
hablaremos sobre los gravámenes un
gravamen es una reclamación sobre la
casa quizás tres dueños atrás no se
pagaron los impuestos de la propiedad y
la ciudad dice bueno quien quiera que
sea el dueño de esta casa me debe mil
dólares de impuestos quizá cuatro dueños
atrás alguien que le hizo mejoras esta
casa nunca le pagó al arquitecto que le
hizo las mejoras así que este arquitecto
tiene una reclamación o demanda sobre
esta casa y dice que cualquier persona
que se esté beneficiando con el trabajo
que él hizo el de mejorar la casa le
sigue debiendo dinero y sólo así se
quitará esa demanda o reclamación sobre
la casa y la forma de evitar esto o
prevenir esto en esta sociedad moderna
es que bueno tú dices que vendes esta
casa pero antes de que yo te dé el
dinero voy a hacer una búsqueda de
escrituras voy a asegurarme de que no
tenga gravámenes y voy a asegurarme de
que tú seas el dueño verdadero de esta
propiedad y sólo hasta que yo compruebe
todo esto es que te daré el dinero de la
casa